- Is it true that you wake up
to Marvin Gaye's "Sexual Healing"?
Everyone wants this to be true.
- Oh, God.
I mean, it's-
- Every morning?
- pure poetry.
- Do you just make some coffee
and just put it on?
- I mean,
it, you know it's, I mean, it's poetry.
I'm just hot like an oven, so...
I mean, it starts with that.
I mean, who doesn't wanna start their day,
and it starts with, like-
- Hot like an oven.
- the, you know, the kind of, like,
I think it's the keyboard and then...
♪ Get up get up get up ♪
♪ Wake up wake up ♪
And then...
♪ Oh baby ♪
I'm just hot like an oven.
- Oh, my God.
I need some loving.
- Hot like an oven!
- Don't we all?
Don't we all need some loving, right?
- I'm totally changing my wake-up,
Jesse is clapping from the back.
- It's a great song.
- It is a great song!
- Yeah, it's a great song.
- I just think it's not,
you project.
Like the Olympian,
Elise, she does that too.